Peggy's 16 good evening Baba fans today
we'll be taking a look at the new
campaign mode at Marvel suh-weet story
driven experience supported by the
hilarious commentators Jim and Bob from
Kabul vision partner the greatest game
in the world
come on bull it's story chops the rear
eyes the rights and Reva's bouncing back
to them and the glory to the you in
complete control of their destiny the
first few matches provide newcomers with
all the basics of how to play before
throwing in a full-blown blood ball
experience where each match is unique
with unexpected and surprising events
constantly renewing the gameplay
we'll be introduced to a more human look
at the world of blood vault and the life
in the world and players in the game
including some of its major players who
will take part in the action in your
favour or against it you will enjoy all
the central mechanics of single player
League play tightly woven around the
lore of Blood Bowl level you'll team up
while leading the Reavers back to the
top of their games through helicopter
crashes treachery and shady sponsorship
deals
buckle up Jim it's gonna be a bumpy ride
ball 2 is about to get a little more
personality this September on ps4 Xbox
one and PC